Megan is in Kansas I'm Megan how are you
hey Dave I'm good and I know you're
better than you deserve
fairly fairly predictable we did our
debt-free screen with you a couple years
ago and now we're two babies in a
business later and so it's an honor to
be on the phone with you I am an
entrepreneurial kind of CPA I do tax and
accounting but I go help small business
owners in their office just kind of
their CFO outsourced CFO and our tagline
is helping KC business thrive and I love
it every single day at love what I do
this guy called up he's a manufacturer
and he's kind of getting started he's
experiencing some growth and he's real
excited but he said also I love this
concept of profit first and I would love
a CPA that's trained in profit first and
I thought well that's I don't know if
that's gimmicky or a real thing and I
looked it up and it seems like it's
really just a way to behaviorally make
it so that you put profit first but it's
like you open all these bank accounts
and you put money and you call it profit
and then you pay your expenses and so I
think he's an engineer and then he's got
like a business degree on top of that
and I'm thinking you're just creating
kind of more headache and administrative
work for yourself than you need because
you have the ability to focus on profit
so I was just wondering if you're
familiar at all with profit first as
like a movement I see that it's not
gimmicky and maybe it's for the person
who doesn't understand profit and loss
but I'm wondering if you I thought they
would probably agree with me on this but
I do I've never heard of it but with the
way your what you're describing
everybody tries to find some kind of
dipsy-doodle thing where you can go
around the barn twice and kick your
heels together and all of a sudden it
all works and really it's its revenue
minus expenses equals profit yeah and
none of that happens if you don't love
your customer right and profit is a sign
that your customer loves you back
profit is the applause that your
customer gives you for doing a good job
the reason I've sold 7 million Total
Money Makeover books is because the book
helps people that's where it comes from
and that's and so I don't put profit
first I actually put people first and
profit is a byproduct of that
yes I'm in complete agreement and I
didn't really after reading it all about
it I thought well if that's the kind of
CPA you wanted everyone really not your
gal because I'm not going to spend time
opening up ten bake accounts for you
just so that you put money in the right
one you move the pan around if you move
the P around another five different
shells it's still one P right you can
you can run it through six bank accounts
and it doesn't grow from running it
through bank accounts I mean and if you
can't if you're not disciplined enough
emotionally to go revenue minus cost of
goods sold minus expenses equals profit
you probably don't need to start a
business I mean that's like sixth grade
crap right there yep I did that stuff
mowing lawns when I was twelve you know
it's not it's not rocket science and you
know you quickly learn to ascertain the
you know do estimating properly on the
time you're gonna spend on a project the
cost of the project the cost of the
goods sold and you know and then you
develop are we really making money here
I mean you know I took one yard to cut
for three dollars it took me ten hours
to cut it I didn't want that yard
anymore you know and so you learn that
stuff but you don't have to run it
through four bank accounts to figure it
out it's just it starts to be basic math
and common sense so I honestly do not
know this system that you're talking
about but the way you're describing it
that's the sense I get is that it sounds
very it does sound gimmicky to me and it
there's no amount of moving money around
through bank accounts that makes money
grow and by the way I don't think you
should put profit first you can you put
your customer first wisely thereby
creating a profit you have to keep your
business model in mind you have to look
at what your expenses are that's right
but if you don't love your customer if
you're not a fan of your customer if
they're a necessary evil for you to be
in business you're probably not gonna
make it
you've got to love them
we teach that around here to our 900
people every day we exist in this
building for those of you that are not
here